Michael Lee with the athletic Kauai out there on the Korg Messiah just said you're the
Messiah just said you're the best player to League in he plays in Toronto
What does it feel like to hear that said about you and how?
Do you feel you've established yourself in that position doing this playoff run? I
Mean I don't really judge my
you know game like
I'm more of a team team aspect see what my team is doing. Just want to win home
I don't care about being the best player
I want to be the best team always said that and you know
Just before the season when we made the trade. I saw I felt that way about me
he told me how he felt and why you made the trade and
you know, its turning out, it's turning out well now I mean when the finals and we 're not done yet